okay hello
so last time we discussed the
pentose phosphate pathway which can
serve as this shunt from
glycolysis where glucose
can be converted to 5-carbon ribulose
15150
bisphosphate um generating nadph
and ribose and
this shunt from glycolysis can work with
the non-oxidative pathway where those
five carbon units can then be used by
the non-oxidative pathway
to re-enter glycolysis giving cells an
ability
to generate nadph now we described that
this non-oxidative pathway can also
operate in the reverse direction such
that cells can take products of
glycolysis
and instead use them to generate ribose
for
for nucleotides and avoid the production
of nadph
really giving cells the flexibility to
either
make nadph when they need it make ribose
when they need it
with the ability to either operate in
this direction as a shunt and allow
nadph to be produced
and material to re-enter glycolysis for
further oxidation
or to just generate ribose if they have
enough nadph
and they simply need that for nucleotide
synthesis
now we spent some time discussing that
nadph is a
key molecule that allows cells to do
reductive reactions this includes
the biosynthesis of reduced carbon which
is of course the way that
nature stores energy for later use
we saw this used as a way to make
reduced carbon
as carbohydrates and photosynthesis and
of course
can also be used to generate fatty acids
which is the most reduced form of carbon
that all organisms can have to to store
energy for later
and the topic of today is really to go
through the pathway that
all organisms use to produce those
fatty acids and lipids as a way to store
um this this uh energy is reduced carbon
for later
now you'll notice i drew up there as a
introduction for the reminder of what we
talked about last time
with the pentose phosphate pathways
really layering it on top of many of the
other pathways in central carbon
metabolism that we've already
discussed and i drew it that way because
i want to show that
you know you already know quite a bit if
you think back to the very beginning
where we had this complex metabolic
pathway chart
well we've already been able to build
quite a
complex network of how metabolism works
and really at this point you know the
basics so
today's lectures and the three lectures
after it so the four remaining lectures
that we have in this course
we're going to cover an awful lot of
material because of course
we have to discuss how all of the
remaining classes of
biomolecules lipids nucleic acids
proteins
link into the rest of of
of metabolism which is an awful lot to
cover but
what you will see is that in
understanding the basics and the
complexity of what we've already
described
you actually know already most of what
you need to know to understand these
remaining pathways
that is nature continues to repurpose
the same relatively simple reactions
over and over and over again to really
build
this complex network that is metabolism
including this diversity
of of macromolecules now of course
there's a
few bits of chemistry that we still have
to discuss we haven't discussed much in
terms of nitrogen metabolism
but most of what you need to know you've
already
covered in understanding glycolysis the
tca cycle
pentose phosphate pathway etc okay
so now on to the topic of the day which
is
really lipids and fatty acid
synthesis and so again i want to
reiterate that organisms store energy is
reduced carbon
fat is the most reduced form of carbon
to store
and so if we're going to generate fat we
need a source of electrons because if
we're going to reduce carbon
something else has to be oxidized that
is those electrons have to come
from somewhere and as hopefully as clear
to you
those electrons will come from nadph
because it
forms this useful electron donor for
cells
now it should also hopefully be clear at
this point that if
oxidation of carbon releases energy
reduction of carbon therefore needs
energy input
and so we're also going to need a bunch
of atp if we're going to make
fat and so atp and nadph are really the
energetic drivers of how we're going to
um take more oxidized
carbon and reduce it to build fatty
acids
now all organisms use similar pathways
to do this but of course the sources of
where the nadph and the atp come from
can be different depending on the
organism and so
we described photosynthesis as this
process used by photosynthetic organisms
where they can use the light reactions
of photosynthesis to make both
atp and nadph and we described how that
atp and nadph could be used to drive
synthesis of glucose
or or other carbohydrates and
effectively
you can also imagine that that same atp
and nadph from the light reactions
could also be used to form the
electron donors and the atp needed to to
synthesize fats and lipids but of course
as animals we also know that if we eat
too much we also have the ability to
store
excess energy as fat and therefore
we must also have sources of nadph and
atp that we can use that are
non-photosynthetic
and those of course are the reactions
that we've already talked about with
glycolysis and the tca cycle oxado
phosphorylation is a way to make atp
as well as nadph from reactions like the
oxidative pentose phosphate pathway as a
source of
nadph now
eukaryotes will make fatty acids
in the cytosol
um and if you think about
why that is it's because mitochondria
remember is where we did
fatty acid oxidation and so fatty acid
oxidation is breaking down fatty acids
fatty acid synthesis building fatty
acids
one set of reactions is in the cytosol
synthesis
one set is in the mitochondria breakdown
makes sense remember compartmentalized
metabolism gives you this ability to
favor different pathways
mitochondria is better at oxidative
reactions cytosol is going to be better
at reductive reactions
and also this compartmentalization will
keep catabolism and anabolism
separate so another example of a point
that we've been making
over and over again throughout this
course
now if we look up here at our diagram
we're going to make
fatty acids from two carbon
acetyl coa units okay
and so remember when we broke down fatty
acids
most fatty acids were even in number
that's allowed us to break them down
into acetyl coa units
well we're also going to build them with
two carbon acetyl coa units
and so this is also contributes to why
most fatty acids in nature
have even numbers of carbons
now you'll also recall from our past
lectures the fatty acids are often
esterified to alcohols
those can be things such as
glycerol-based alcohols which allow us
to form lipids either triacylglycerides
those neutral lipids for energy storage
or phospholipids to form
membranes and that of course
comes from a branch of glycerol of
course comes from
from dihydroxyacetone phosphate um a
molecule
in in a glycolysis
now of course i'm not going to draw
acetyl coa now i'll draw it later but
remember it is not reduced and so
that's where we're going to need the
electrons from nadph
as well as atp for the energetic
requirements
in order to take those two carbon units
build the acyl chain
and ultimately reduce them to make fat
now when we do this you're going to see
that carbon dioxide as well as
biotin okay so you might be thinking oh
what's biotin used for it's a
carboxylation reaction and so co2 in a
carboxylation
reaction involving biotin is going to be
required
for fatty acid synthesis however
you will also see that that co2 carbon
is not incorporated
into the fatty acyl chain and so
you'll see that the co2 is required
but ultimately is added and released
which is exactly the same analogy to
what we saw when we did gluconeogenesis
remember the pyruvate carboxylase pepsi
k reaction and gluconeogenesis if you
look back
a co2 was added to make oxaloacetate to
pyruvate to make oxaloacetate
and then released later to generate pep
that helped drive the energetics of that
reaction no net co2 incorporation
very similar thing happening in fatty
acid
synthesis now in
animals mammals
much of fatty acid
synthesis
is catalyzed by a giant
single polypeptide enzyme
called fast n or fatty acid synthase
complex
which is a unlike other complexes we've
talked about where you might have
different
polypeptide subunits coming together
form a complex
this is one gigantic polypeptide
that is able to catalyze many of the
enzymatic steps of
fatty acid synthesis now a bit of trivia
is that this is different from plants
and bacteria
which will carry out the exact same
enzymatic reactions
however it will have rather than using
a giant fatty acid synthase complex will
have all the different enzymatic
activities
broken up and catalyzed by different um
proteins separately encoded polypeptides
now all organisms will do this
using
a protein called acyl
carrier
protein and so
acyl carrier protein you'll see is
really analogous
to acetyl coa so it's a way to add a
thioester
mark a separate pool and we'll carry the
growing
fatty acyl chain as we synthesize it
okay
so acyl carrier protein
is part of
fassen the big polypeptide fast n
in mammals that catalyze this thing the
acyl carrier protein is not separate
it's actually built
in to the sequence of fassen whereas
acyl carrier protein in
plants and bacteria is a small nine
kilodalton
protein okay
all right so in mammals acyl carrier
protein part of the fatty acid synthase
polypeptide
implants and bacteria acyl carrier
protein is a small
nine kilodalton protein and so
what acyl carrier protein looks like
is that as part of this nine kilodalton
protein
or sequence within fassen
there is a serine residue
remember serine has an alcohol on its
side
chain and that alcohol on its side chain
has a phosphodiester bond to a
pant uh phosphopantothenoid
group just like we saw with coenzyme a
okay so if you look back in your notes
when i drew out
coenzyme a the business end of the
molecule
was right here with the
sulfur on the end there being the one
that formed the
phosphodiester bond this one rather than
being linked to a nucleoside in this
case is linked to
a serine as part of a peptide and so
this is why it's very very similar
so this year same as
end of
coenzyme a and so really you
can think of acp acyl carrier protein
and coenzyme a in some ways analogous to
how we talked about nad and nadph
same functionality in this case
providing a sulfur to make these
uh um thioester bonds
as a way to activate that um
the the acid on the end of the fatty
acid
one use for synthesis one used for
breakdown acyl carrier protein used for
synthesis
coenzyme a acyl coas
used for for oxidation whereas in member
nad and nadp
one was used to create an nad nadh ratio
that favored oxidative reactions
the other used to create an nadp and
adph ratio
that favored reductive reactions even
though
they were different um uh you know
you know even though the functionality
the electron donor in the case of nad
and nadp
or in this case the the carrier function
um
with with with the uh thioester bond
in acp and um and and
coenzyme a are analogous really allows
you to mark different pools to carry out
in this case anabolic and catabolic
reactions in cells
so often we will abbreviate this just as
we
abbreviated co-a as sort of
coash or s-coa in this case we're going
to use
acp sh is an abbreviation
for acyl carrier protein
however remember just like coenzyme a
was this giant molecule it kind of is a
little misleading to write it this way
acyl carrier protein is an even bigger
molecule a nine kilo dalton peptide in
plants and bacteria
and so again misleading to write it this
way because it's really this giant group
um linked to and carrying the
the acyl chain
okay
now the first step in fatty acid
synthesis
is carboxylation of acetyl-coa
this is a very important step of the
process
and it is not catalyzed by the fatty
acid synthase
complex the the the fatty acid synthase
protein
in in mammals and so in all organisms
it is a separate catalyzed by a separate
enzyme
abbreviated acc which stands for
acetyl acetyl-coa carboxylase
so acc is a pretty famous enzyme
it's the argued by many to be the rate
limiting step
in in fatty acid synthesis
and it makes sense because you're going
to see this is we're doing a
carboxylation reaction
big energetics here um and that
is obviously as we learned before the
steps that you regulate are the ones
with the biggest
change in in free energy
so
here's our old friend acetyl coa
and what acc carries out
is it carries out the
has a biotin bound in the active site
which of course can contain a co2
just as a quick reminder how do we put
co2 on biotin for carboxylation
reactions
and so remember co2 is in
equilibrium with
bicarbonate that bicarbonate
can be phosphorylated by adp
to give
this phospho um
phospho bicarbonate and then
that phosphate can be released
to add
the co2 onto the active biotin
part of the enzyme that then carries
that co2
and can be used to transfer
the co2 to carboxylate in this
example acetyl coa
to generate this carboxylated acetyl
coa3 carbon molecule
which is referred to as malonyl coa
all right so this is exactly the same
mechanism that we described before
for pyruvate carboxylase in
gluconeogenesis
all right so i drew out part of it here
remember if we draw
acetyl coa
in the enol form of the molecule
okay and here we have our biotin
co2 if you look back at your notes
we drew a mechanism like that and that
allowed us to
um in that case take pyruvate and turn
it into oxaloacetate
and gluconeogenesis by pyruvate
carboxylase in this case
identical reaction but this time you're
carboxylating acetyl coa to make
malonyl coa right and it's
coa that ends up being the substrate
for fatty acid synthase either
the single fatty acid synthase protein
in mammals or the same
sets of individually encoded activities
on different polypeptides in
plants and bacteria all right
so let's draw this out so here's
fatty acid synthase and so fatty acid
synthase
has on it two different acyl carrier
protein sites a two different eso
carrier protein
encoded within the fatty acid synthase
polypeptide
each of which have attached to them this
phosphopentanoate group
to make it an acyl carrier protein or
there would be two separate apical
carrier proteins in plants and bacteria
as part of
the complex that synthesizes fatty acids
and each of them can pick up
a
acyl coa
so here's a malonyl coa
and an acetyl coa
each of those can basically
onto the acyl carrier protein exchange
the thioester bond with the coa to be a
thioester bond
with the acyl carrier protein
and so
and so to get this started on one site
you'll end up going in acetyl coa
exchange the thioester bond such that
you release the coa and now you have an
acetyl
acp and on the other side a malonyl coa
exchanged the thioester bond releasing
the coa so you have a malonyl
acp all right so what does that look
like well
it'll look like this
okay so here we're going to have and
basically
use some color so you can see what's
going on but here you have
on an upper acyl carrier protein site
the malonyl group so malonyl acp
and on this lower site i put on an
acetyl
acp okay so
happens is you now release the co2
that was
added by acetyl-coa carboxylase
and that allows forming carbon bond from
here to here
releasing the acp
on the lower site
and
generating
this longer four carbon chain
on the upper
acyl carrier protein site
okay once you have this
now four carbon chain
obviously if we're going to make a fatty
acid we have to reduce
this carbon and so that's exactly what
happens and so how do we reduce it
we've now seen this many many times and
so if we use
nadph as an electron donor
oxidizing it to nadp plus
that generates
this hydride ion to electron carrier
and now
we net reduce this ketone to
this alcohol okay next step is
we're going to remove water across
that bond just a dehydration
you
all right now we can
further reduce that carbon-carbon
bond electrons again
come from nadph
as it's oxidized to nadp
plus
and that leaves us with
a reduced four carbon
fatty acid a four zero fatty acid here
on this
sterified via this thioester to acp
on the upper site of fatty acid
synthase okay all right
so what happens
well we can repeat this cycle so now we
can have
basically this
sacp on the lower site
pick up a
a maloneyl koa
release the koa and then we have
down here a another
malayal koa
now they're certified to the acp
on the lower side all right now
we can run this exact same
series of reactions again
okay
that releases co2
also releases a free
sacp on the
upper side and now
we are left with this
a
this now six carbon molecule
with a thioester now on the acp on
the lower side all right hopefully
you're getting
the point i can now take this through
the same
cycles i took before or first we're
going to
use nadph to reduce this ketone
to the alcohol the dehydration
use nadph again to
reduce the carbon-carbon double bond and
we are left with now a
this sapp on the lower side
i can now run this cycle
five times or add another malonyl coa
this time to the upper site combine them
now you have this growing chain on the
upper site
reduction add another malony coat to the
lower site blah blah blah
run it five times eventually i'm going
to end up with a
16 0 fatty acell
acp and then i can take that
exchange it back
for a coa and i end up with a
16 carbon fatty acyl
coa or palmitial
coa molecule
such that all of the carbons added
came from acetyl coa except for one
all of that acetyl-coa was added by
first
adding a co2 via acetyl-coa carboxylase
generating a malonyl coa that's spending
atp
to put the carboxyl group on because of
course we needed to spend an atp in the
acetyl-coa reaction
um and so seven cycles
were needed to generate this 16-0 fatty
acyl coa
and so those seven cycles were
seven atp molecules i also needed
two times seven or 14 nadph
molecules
and that allowed me to run this cycle
17 times and make a fully reduced
16 carbon fatty acid
now it turns out that all of this
activity stops on the fatty acid
synthase
um molecule when it gets to a 16 carbon
palmiteal coa but of course as we
described before
organisms have longer
fatty acids then 16 carbons
and so 18 carbon and longer
fatty acids are made in exactly
the same chemistry okay same reactions
that we just described the only
difference is
that they are not made on the fatty acid
synthase complex
so they're made in a different location
and so they're made at the
er membrane
in eukaryotes
all right so the er and eukaryotes
the
the enzymes even though the enzymes
themselves carry out the same reaction
the enzymes that carry out this are
encoded
by different
polypeptides so-called fatty acid
elongase
um enzymes although the chemistry is
exactly what we already described
and but those enzymes act on the coa
on the thioester with the coa not
the thioester with the acyl carrier
protein
but it's still the same there's still
one
atp per acetyl coa
for two carbon unit added because that
atp is needed to carboxylate it to make
the malonyl coa because that's what's
driving
the addition and two
[Music]
nad ph's
per two carbon unit added
to carry out the reduction um to take
that
uh carbonyl from the acetyl-coa or the
malonyl coa that's added
as a two-carbon unit and reduce it to
the fully reduced
carbon okay and so
that is how you make saturated fatty
acids
so what about unsaturated fatty acids
well
it is not that you just stop and don't
make it fully saturated nature first
makes a fully saturated fatty acid
and then it comes back and re-oxidizes
the fully saturated fatty acid
to introduce double bonds in the
um right positions and so for
unsaturated
so you start with
a saturated
fatty acid
of the desired length
so you make that first and then
you use so-called desaturase
enzymes
to introduce
double bonds at the desired
location
all right so it's a little
counterintuitive
but this is effectively why you end up
with double bonds at the stereotyped
places remember the delta nine position
is the
first place when we describe the
nomenclature of fatty acids
where we always put the first double
bond
why does nature do it this way well it's
very hard to say that but you can
imagine
evolution of how you would get these
enzyme activities
it's hard to evolve a fatty acid
synthase complex that would
stop um you know doing
uh the reduction reaction only at
specific locations and so
you probably first generate these fatty
acids
fully saturated because that's the way
an enzyme could do it
and then later have a different enzyme
that can pick out a location on a
saturated fatty acid
to introduce a double bond
all right so how can we introduce a
double bond well that's an oxidation
reaction
and so if we're going to do an oxidation
reaction
we need a place for the electrons that
we move so if we oxidize
the fatty acid that's removing electrons
those electrons have to go somewhere
you might imagine if we're oxidizing a
carbon-carbon bond we've seen that
reaction before
um you know when we did succinate to
fumarate
okay succinate dehydrogenase that was an
oxidation reaction we used fad
we saw it with the fatty acid
breakdown when i we first put the double
bond in
we used fad and so indeed
fad is used in this reaction but it does
not work
like other fad reactions to
carry out this oxidation for whatever
reason
the way desaturases work is different
okay so these desaturase reactions
use oxygen as a final
electron acceptor
and they work
via a mini
electron transport chain in the er
in eukaryotes okay so it's a little bit
of a
different weird mechanism but if we
think here's our
carbon-carbon bond that we're going to
oxidize to introduce a double bond
and desaturate our lipid and so
so what is that well it's basically
this reaction okay so
this is rather than just remove this as
a hydride ion
it turns out that those electrons go to
oxide to oxygen which of course will
generate one water molecule but there's
two oxygens there so you need to
generate a second water molecule
those electrons have to come from
somewhere else and those electrons come
from this
little mini electron
transport chain
so if we oxidize iron
we can get electrons from that reaction
and so this ends up generating
a
double bond in the fatty acid with
two of the electrons going to oxygen and
the other two electrons coming from this
mini electron transport chain in this
desaturase
complex in the endoplasmic reticulum
all right and so of course those
electrons have to come from
somewhere um so we have to re-um reduce
this iron we oxidize to get the
electrons from
and so this works
by an electron transport chain similar
to what we saw before where it's this
whole series
of oxidation and reduction reactions
that does happen to involve
fad and fadh2 but ultimately
the electrons are coming from nadh
so oxidation of nadh
ultimately is providing electrons that
together with oxidation here lead the to
the reduction of
oxygen to water and you can of course
read more about this if you're
interested in it
but it's important to point out that
this process works via slightly
different mechanism
than you might predict from
sort of the general principles of the
way most double bonds are introduced
in carbon column molecules and
metabolism
why it works this way is something we
can
only speculate about okay
now mammals are
only
use a desaturate enzyme
that in a fully saturated fatty acid
can only introduce
a double bond
at the delta nine position that is
between
carbons 9 and 10 of a fatty
of a fully saturated
fatty acid
and that's because they only have an
enzyme complex that does that so that is
you know they can take an 18 0 newly
synthesized fatty acid
and they can make an 18 1 or we can make
an 18
1 delta 9 fatty acid
okay that's the only desaturates enzyme
we have to
put into a saturated fatty acid that is
to make
completely a de novo unsaturated fatty
acid
which is one of the reasons why we don't
have a lot of polyunsaturated fatty
acids
now we do have enzyme complexes that
work similarly to these they can add
double bonds at other locations but they
have to start having a double bond
already present in those locations
many of those lipids have to come from
the diet and that's that concept of
essential lipids something that we have
to eat from a plant and bacteria that
already has a double bond there in order
to add double bonds
to make some of our other
polyunsaturated fatty acids
all right so that's how
fatty acids are made
but as i alluded to earlier all of this
is taking place in the cytosol
and if we're doing all of this work in
the cytosol maybe you notice that we
actually have another problem that
nature
has to solve okay and that is
because we're doing all this from acetyl
coa
and so we have to have acetyl coa in the
cytosol to have this work
but acetyl coa all the ways we've talked
here most of the ways we've talked about
it producing it
happen in the mitochondria remember acyl
coa can't get across the mitochondrial
membrane so we need a way to get acetyl
coa out of the mitochondria into the
cytosol
for this whole thing to work put another
way so if we draw here here's glucose to
pyruvate that's glycolysis
remember to turn
that pyruvate into
acetyl coa we had to move the pyruvate
into the mitochondria
that's where the ph complex was
to generate the acetyl-coa but if we
need
acetyl-coa in the cytosol
for fatty acid synthase to make
fatty acids
we basically need a way to get that
acetyl coa
back out of the mitochondria in order to
generate
fatty acids other big sources of
esteocoa
remember it was if we start with a fatty
acid in the mitochondria
okay run fatty acid oxidation
again fatty acid oxidation in the
mitochondria generates acetyl coa in the
mitochondria
we're going to use it to rebuild a fatty
acid need to get it out of the
mitochondria
into the cytosol coenzyme a
is not membrane permeable and so we need
remember we had shuttles to get fatty
acids into the mitochondria
we did the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction here to begin with
and so it's a problem to get this giant
coa acetyl coa the coa from the
acetyl-coa
out of the mitochondria into the cytosol
okay so one solution to this
to getting acetyl coa in the cytosol
is simply to start with acetate okay
that is take the coa group off and just
have
an acetate molecule and of course
acetate or acetic acid well that's food
that's vinegar
all right the salad you ate has acetate
in it acetyl coa
it can be in the cytosol we can make
acetate if you look back at your notes
about how we metabolized
alcohol so alcohol gets metabolized to
acetate
and so that acetate in the cytosol
we can just add a coa group to it in the
cytosol
and how do we do that well we saw the
reaction to do this already
okay and this is basically
when we added any fatty acid
to make a fatty acyl coa remember the
free fatty acid turn it into a fatty
acyl coa
we had this reaction where we used atp
we added the amp to it
and then that doing pyrophosphate can
drive it forward with the two
pyrophosphate molecules and then take
the amp off and
adds a coe group if you look back in
your notes it's the identical reaction
to how we made a fatty acyl coa
well there's also an enzyme that can act
on acetate
and do this to make acetyl coa
and that's great it's a way to make
acetyl coa in the cytosol if you start
with
acetate however this is
not the way it works if you already have
an acetyl-coa
in the mitochondria okay
and so if in the mitochondria
you already have an acetylene
coa okay so this can come from
pyruvate
via the pdh reaction it can come from
fatty acid oxidation okay this acetyl
coa in the mitochondria
all right well what do we talk about
doing
with it in the tca cycle well the tca
cycle we can use citrate synthase
to generate this
citrate molecule and it turns out
citrate
itself can be used as a carrier to
export
the acetyl-coa from the mitochondria
to the cytosol
such that now when you have citrate
in the cytosol that citrate
can now be
used where you basically carry out the
opposite
of the citrate synthase reaction to
regenerate
acetyl coa and oxaloacetate
well if one direction is favorable the
other direction is going to be not
favorable and so you need
energy input in one of the directions
and so this
costs you atp
and this is carried out by an enzyme
called
atp citrate
lyase often abbreviated acl
why so
atp citrate lyse allows you to basically
reverse the citrate synthase reaction
such that you can
shuttle acetyl-coa out of the
mitochondria to the cytosol
using citrate as a molecule
and then of course that oxaloacetate
can be shuttled back into the
mitochondria via something like the
malate aspartate shuttle which we
described
um several lectures ago as a way to make
this
a complete cycle
i want to spend a little bit of time
talking about this because here a lot of
metabolism begins to come together
all right and so
when do you want to produce fatty acids
we want to produce fatty acids when you
have a lot of atp
and so if you have a lot of atp this is
a situation where
the tca cycle isn't going to want to run
and so that favors
citrate export from the tca cycle
into the cytosol remember citrate was
this important regulator
of glycolysis okay we talked about you
have a lot of citrate let's slow down
glycolysis
well that citrate in the cytosol also
now
provides a source of acetyl coa to take
all that extra carbon
and turn it into fatty acids all right
we also in the process of moving this
out we generate
oxaloacetate remember oxaloacetate of
course
is part of the malate acetate shuttle
we'll come back to that in a minute
but oxaloacetate in the cytosol that was
the product of the pyruvate carboxylase
reaction
to get oxaloacetate in the cytosol so
pepsi k can make
um pep and do gluconeogenesis
and so the same thing is also taking
oxaloacetate
and putting that in the cytosol where
it's a good thing to do gluconeogenesis
which is something else that you want to
do
if you have a lot of excess atp to store
carbon
and so this is really set up in a way
that now you have your citrate and
oxaloacetate and the cytosol
which are the starting points to
generate either fat
or carbohydrate as a way to store excess
energy
if you have um plenty of atp around
now it turns out that oxaloacetate in
the cytosol
is also beneficial in another way
because it can be part of a series of
enzyme reactions
that also benefits um
fatty acid synthesis
and that's because it's a substrate
for an enzyme it can create a substrate
and create malate
that's a substrate for an enzyme called
um malic
enzyme which is another way to generate
nadph
all right so let's go through this so
remember
oxaloacetate differs from malate
by an oxidation reduction reaction so
remember
we described malate dehydrogenase in the
tca cycle to turn malate into
oxaloacetate
and the malate aspartate shuttle we
pointed out that this enzyme can run in
reverse
and so can be used to
regenerate nad in the cytosol
and is this oxaloacetate back to malate
as part of the mallite aspartate shuttle
was a way to regenerate nad to help keep
glycolysis going
as an alternative to fermentation get
those electrons into the mitochondria so
we give them
to oxygen well this malate
that's made is a substrate not just for
the mallite aspartate shuttle to bring
electrons into the mitochondria
but is also a substrate for an enzyme
called
malic enzyme
and malic enzyme is a way to make nadph
well how does this
work so here's
okay so here's malate
all right so
if we
re-oxidize this alcohol
to bring malate back to oxaloacetate
okay so that generates
hydride ion which can of course
be given to a nicotinamide group and
malic enzyme
nicotinamide group is nadp plus to
generate
nadph nadph is of course useful
for reducing power to make fatty acids
so what does this generate well this
generates
again all i've done is regenerate
oxaloacetate
okay so this is oxaloacetate
but turns out this oxaloacetate is
retained on the enzyme
and remember oxaloacetate is a beta
keto acid okay so acid group
alpha beta okay
beta ketoacid
and beta decarboxylation
is favorable okay we've now seen this
many many times this is going to
generate
enol pyruvate
enol pyruvate we'll run a rearrange to
pyruvate okay
right and so effectively i can turn
malate
into pyruvate and generate nadph
and that's what malec enzyme does and if
you look back at the malate aspartate
shuttle
we used oxaloacetate to make malate and
it was malate
that was sent back to the mitochondria
well here we can also
use it to make pyruvate and then the
pyruvate can go back to the mitochondria
and use pyruvate carboxylase to generate
oxaloacetate
pyruvate carboxylase as a way to do
anaplerosis for this mini cycle if you
want
a lot of moving parts here let me be
explicit about what's going on
and show you how i can build
a series of reactions here that is very
useful
if i want to generate fat
okay so here's glycolysis
remember to run glycolysis
i need a source of nad plus for the gap
dh reaction
if i'm not going to ferment the pyruvate
i need to deal with that nad plus
well if i send now that pyruvate here
into the mitochondria right
that pyruvate can go through the
pyruvate dehydrogenase reaction
make acetyl coa
acetyl coa combine
with oxaloacetate to make citrate
okay
export that citrate
from the mitochondria to the cytosol
run the atp
citrate lys reaction
now i have acetyl coa in the cytosol
and can use that to generate
fatty acids and of course
that requires
nad ph as reducing power
to make those fatty acids okay
so all series of
reactions that you've seen many many
times
glycolysis
pyruvate dehydrogenase citrate synthase
atp citrate lyse that we just described
and of course this over here
acetyl coa carboxylase of course and
fatty acid synthase to do that all right
now that's great but we have
this nad plus to deal with
and we need sources of nadph to balance
all the electrons
to make this work let's show how we can
incorporate malate dehydrogenase and
malic enzyme as a way
to make all this balanced so if we take
oxaloacetate and make malate
okay
okay this is our
malai dehydrogenase reaction i've now
regenerated the nad i need in the
cytosol
to keep that carbon flowing
in from glucose to make
acetyl-coa right now i have malate
i can use malic enzyme
to turn malate into pyruvate okay
that's going to serve as a source
of nadph that i can use
again nadph in the cytosol to drive
fatty acid
synthase in the cytosol obviously you
need more than one nadph to do this but
at least it generates nadph is reducing
power
to make the fatty acids
and of course take that pyruvate
bring it back in the mitochondria
i can run
the pyruvate carboxylase reaction
and now regenerate oxaloacetate
in the mitochondria and now i have a
balanced cycle
where i can run this cycle to turn
glucose carbon into acetyl coa
for fat and in the process also make
some nadph is reducing power
to support my fatty acid synthase
reaction
this is just one way that i can take all
these reactions
we talked about and build a pathway
that's balanced at least
for the nad nadh oxidation piece
and gives us something useful what gives
us atp from glycolysis and also gives
nadph
from the malic enzyme reaction to do
this and what does it cost me
well it costs me a bunch of atp right
cost me atp here
cost me atp there of course a lot of atp
up here
but you're doing this when there's
energy excess
you have plenty of atp around and it's a
way that nature then can use
this high energy high atp state
as a way to store carbon ultimately is
reduce carbon as fatty acids
that can be used later when times
are not so good all right
so
let's spend a couple minutes talking
about the regulation of fatty acid
synthesis
it's very straightforward not really a
whole lot to talk about
you really only want to make fat if you
have
high atp adp ratio
this is a situation excess citrate in
the cytosol
and so high citrate
which remember inhibits glycolysis well
high citrate is going to
activate
fatty acid synthase okay
the big step though is acetyl coa
carboxylase that's what makes the
malonyl coa that's the big change in
delta g by all the reasons we talked
about before that's the step you want to
regulate
and so it turns out that
high levels of palmitial coa that is the
16o fatty acid the product of the fatty
acid synthase reaction
this is going to
inhibit
acetyl-coa carboxylase makes sense
have a lot of product around
stop making it stop the step that
costs the most that's hardest to go back
um to generate it
okay what's the other thing well you
only want to do this
if cells are
have enough energy to do it what's our
energy charge atp and p ratio if amp is
high
you also want to inhibit a acc
low energy don't try to make fat that's
basically
what you need to know about the
regulation of fatty acid synthase
now of course most that's making fatty
acids but of course
most fatty acids are not floating around
free in nature they're stored as
lipids and so just to remind you here's
a image from an earlier lecture
these were the image of a fat cell as
well as a plant cell here that both
have these lipid droplets that are
filled with these neutral lipids these
triacylglycerides
and so you want to store the fatty acid
for energy you put it into a trial
glyceride pop it into a lipid droplet
and now you have this efficient way to
store
all this reduced carbon without having
to carry around the weight of the water
or maybe you want to use this to
generate membranes right
phospholipids you need to generate
phospholipids both trial glycerides
phospholipids are built on this
glycerol backbone and i just want to
mention briefly the pathway that cells
really use or a pathway the cells use
to make these glycerol-based lipids
and so as we talked about
before here's our old friend
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
from glycolysis remember if we
um if we uh
reduce this um this ketone
to the alcohol that's how we made
uh made glycerol it turns out
first before doing this the way nature
does it
is it first adds the fatty acid so
it takes the fatty acyl coa releases
the coa and you end up with this
intermediate okay it's
this molecule that then you
reduce of course you can reduce it with
nadh you can also reduce it with
nadph and that gives us
this phospho mono
acyl glycerol okay so
this molecule with that being the
alcohol instead of the ketone
phosphomonolase
now come on add another fatty acyl coa
releasing the coa that gives us a
phosphodiesyl glycerol
so now a fatty acid is sterified to
that middle carbon and then this
phosphodies glycerol we can
remove the phosphate
to get just a diacylglycerol
and then generate a triacyl
glycerol by putting on a third
fatty acid from a fatty acyl coa
releasing the coa
and now we have this triacylglyceride
this neutral lipid that can be packed
into
the uh lipid droplet here
and store energy as reduced carbon
for later that's great but what if we
want to make
a phospholipid
i'll show you briefly how this works
don't worry about the details of this i
just want you to have a flavor
for how this happens because it
illustrates another way that nature
repurposes
the same reactions over and over again
and so
as one releases this phosphate
from the diacylglycerol it now picks up
a head group on there and so
one that can be picked up is
ethanolamine
and the ethanolamine comes from a
molecule
called cdp ethanolamine
if you're interested in the structure of
ethanolamine be reminded of that you can
of course look it up
but basically it's ethanolamine
attached to a cdp group releasing a cmp
group which makes a phospho
ethanolamine
okay and then that phosphoethanolamine
can be turned into phos
or phosphatidyl
ethanolamine the phospholipid
phosphatidylstenolamine can be turned
into phosphatidyl choline
and if you look up the difference
between choline and ethanolamine
is adding three methyl groups and we'll
talk about how to do that
in one of the upcoming lectures all
right
and so here's two of the major
phospholipids phosphatidylcholine
phosphatidylethanolamine
they are added to a diacylglyceride
by basically taking the phosphate off
and adding a phosphate from
cdp ethanolamine releasing
cmp what's cdp ethanolamine
well it's very similar to how we already
talked about
with udp glucose in glycogen metabolism
and so if you start with the
amino alcohol ethanolamine
okay which itself is made from serine
but we don't have time to talk about
how this
can basically
be phosphorylated by
atp to put a phosphate on the alcohol to
make
phosphoethynolamine
okay so you have a phosphoethanol
and then that phosphoethanolamine
can react with a ctp
releasing a pyrophosphate
such that the phospho from the atp
is replaced by the
cdp you end up getting a cdp
ethanolamine with two
uh pyrophosphate coming off via series
of reactions that if you look back in
your notes we'll look identical
to how we made udp glucose and making
glycogen
and then the cdp ethanol amine transfers
the phosphoethynolamine
onto the diazoglyceride to give you the
phosphatidyl
ethanolamine why do i mention this just
because i want you to have a flavor
of how phospholipids are made
realize that here's a repurposing of the
same
series and type of reactions as we saw
for glycogen metabolism but now to make
um phospholipids and also to point out
that it's really expensive
to make a phospholipid all right you
need three atps just to add this ethanol
amine group
to there so that's actually fairly
expensive and so
a lot of energy goes into cells building
these phospholipids now for the last
bit of time today i want to
return to a brief topic of another lipid
and that's this guy here
cholesterol and so you'll remember
that cholesterol is this
complex ring structure
lots of reduced carbon there it's a
molecule that mammals use if you recall
to keep their membranes fluid
okay now mammals of course can make
cholesterol and you all probably have
heard about cholesterol because
its high levels of cholesterol have been
linked to heart disease and so
a lot of people talk about what their
cholesterol levels are something doctors
check a lot
and this has led the recognition that
cholesterol can be associated with
vascular disease has led to the
development of a class of drugs called
statins okay and
statins are one of the most commonly
prescribed drugs out there
they're a drug that blocks an enzyme in
cholesterol synthesis
and have been very effective at lowering
risk
of heart attacks and strokes they've
also been a huge windfall
a huge moneymaker for lots of
pharmaceutical companies
and so if you care about medicine
they're important to medicine if you
care about biotech
they're also were very important in the
supporting the pharmaceutical industry
all right now we don't have time to talk
fully about how cholesterol synthesis
works it's a long pathway
you can look it up if you're interested
you have all the tools that you need to
understand all of the steps
to make cholesterol you'll see you build
it from scl-coa you need a bunch of
nadph
i i don't have time to go through all
those steps but i will discuss the
initial steps so you can understand how
statins work
is because that's important in medicine
and some of you i know want to go to
medical school
but apart from that these early steps
affect other aspects
of biology making lipid tails for
signaling proteins
also introduces a discussion of ketones
which are another important metabolic
fuel that we need to talk about as well
now the way that one makes
these things is basically you start with
three acetyl coa
molecules
okay so here's two acetyl-coa molecules
we can combine those two together
releasing a co-a
and this is really
this is really the identical reaction
that we just saw for the early steps
in fatty acid
synthase
okay that generates this molecule called
acetoacetyl
coa and then this
can combine with yet another
acetyl-coa
to make this molecule
which is called
hydroxymethylglutaral or hmg
coa all right
i don't need to describe any of these
reactions to you as i said this is
just what we showed earlier for fatty
acid synthesis
and this reaction is the identical
reaction
to citrate synthase in the tca cycle and
takes these three
one two three acetyl coas and makes this
molecule
hmg coa hmg coa
is the substrate
for an enzyme called hmg
coa reductase
hmg coa reductase is the
famous target of
statins to block cholesterol synthesis
what hmg coa reductase does is it
releases that coa group
and
uses two nadph
oxidizing it to two nad plus that
effectively is um
when you release this coa what are you
left with the acid you reduce it twice
and you end up with the alcohol and that
gives you this molecule
which is called mevelonate
and mevelonate is
what you use to build cholesterol
and so statins by blocking hmg coa
reductase
basically block the reactions that are
necessary to make the precursor
mevolonate which is necessary to make
cholesterol
and that's why statins stop cholesterol
synthesis
now mevylonate it turns out
is also used for other things in cells
it's not just used
to make cholesterol it's also used to
make a class of molecules called
isoprenoids
isoprenoids are important and you'll
encounter them if you study signaling or
anything like that
because these make things like the
farnesylation
um
lipid modifications that are oftentimes
added to
membrane associated proteins like
signaling proteins
and so statins will also block the
production
of these molecules that are important
for these various
signaling proteins and so you should
have some
understanding of what mevelon it is
where it comes from how that it's
involved in cholesterol
and isoprenate synthesis and then it's
the target of
statins and of course you didn't need a
whole lot you already have all the tools
to understand
that pathway and if you look up
isoprenoid synthesis cholesterol
synthesis
you'll see you'll have the tools to um
understand that
as well now the last thing i want to
talk about
is taking that aceto
the acetoacetyl coa and if i take the
coa group off
what i'm left with is a molecule called
acetoacetate okay this
is basically two acetyl coast
brought together losing co-a's times two
and that
okay so this here is acetoacetate
and acetoacetate is a canonical
ketone body
what is a ketone body well it turns out
ketones are an
alternative fuel that the body can use
to glucose
primarily the brain and so for reasons
that no one really understands a quirk
of
of uh of human and mammalian physiology
is that the brain prefers to use glucose
as its fuel
if glucose is not available it doesn't
use fatty acids it use ketone
bodies instead and so the ketone
acetoacetate
is the canonical ketone body
this underlies the keto diet which has
become very popular
and so what is the keto diet well the
keto diet is you don't eat any
carbohydrates
and so if you don't eat carbohydrates
you
don't have a source of glucose the liver
of course can do gluconeogenesis
but if you run out of things to make and
turn into glucose
now the liver gets into trouble remember
we talked about with anaplerosis of the
tca cycle
there's no way to turn two carbon units
that are made from fat the acetyl coa
from fat
you can't turn that mammals cannot turn
that back into glucose because we don't
have the glyoxylate
um cycle and so we can't turn fat
into glucose and so when the liver can
no longer make glucose
it will take acetyl coa from the
breakdown of fat
and make ketones instead and the ketone
is this acetoacetate
people do the keto diet because ketones
like acetoacetate will suppress
appetite and that's at least how it one
way it's thought to work
but i want to talk about what these
ketones are
and how they fit into metabolism
so here's acetoacetate if you notice
acetoacetate is a beta
carboxylic a beta ketoacid
okay alpha beta the acid is
the ketone is beta to the acid group so
a beta
keto acid as i've said now
many many many times beta-keto acids
can
undergo decarboxylation that generates
the enol
which can be rearranged to the keto
group
and in that case what's the keto group
well the keto group
would be this molecule which is acetone
fingernail polish remover if you go to
medical school you'll learn that if
of type 1 diabetics have a state of
physiology called beta
called ketoacidosis so we don't have
time to go into what drives that state
that physiological state
but it's basically a state with very
high ketones
they smell like acetone the reason is is
because they have very high levels of
acetoacetate the ketone body
and some of that spontaneously
decarboxylates to make
acetone all right the body does this
though it's making
the acetoacetate as a way to give food
to the brain
but because acetoacetate is unfavorable
that's not the form that is put into the
blood
instead it undergoes an oxidation
reduction reaction where this ketone
is um reduced to
the alcohol or interconverted between
the ketone and the alcohol
something gets oxidized something else
gets reduced nadn adh is the donor
and that leads to this molecule
which is called beta hydroxybutyrate
and beta hydroxybutyrate is the
canonical
ketone that circulates in your blood and
measurement of beta-hydroxybutyrate
levels really tells you if you're really
doing
the ketone diet properly
so basically your liver
if it doesn't have enough glucose will
have to break down fat
can't turn the acetyl coa from fat into
glucose so unsettle to turn it into
acetoacetate
which will convert to the more stable
beta hydroxybutyrate
and then the more stable beta
hydroxybutyrate can be oxidized
by peripheral tissues predominantly the
brain as an alternative source of fuel
to glucose when the liver can't maintain
glucose two why this happens this way
no one really knows why it uses ketones
instead of that but it fits
with all the physiology and it also fits
the metabolism that we've already
learned about
um to see why it works this way
and i just want to point out for those
of you who are doing the keto diet to do
it properly
yes you have to limit carbohydrates
that's the most popular way to do it
but to really make this work you also
have to eliminate
other sources of carbon that can be used
for gluconeogenesis
mostly amino acids so lowering protein
so a true ketogenic diet is really all
fat
because that is what basically
makes acetyl coa really the only carbon
source that the liver can use
and then it has to only generate ketones
beta-hydroxybutyrate which then
circulates as an alternative
oxidizable carbon source for the brain
okay thanks so much